yo creo que benefician a la
población pero también tenemos que tener
en cuenta que mantenerla la ciudad
abierta quizás no sea la mejor opción
para aquellos niños que todavía no han
podido ser vacunados y que por eso y
otros estamos observando este incremento
en las hospitalizaciones dentro de la
ciudad
bueno inicialmente se dijo que el 19 se
manifestaba de manera más leve en los
niños y adolescentes sin embargo nueva
york que registra un incremento de
hospitalización en pediátricas de al
menos un 30% usted que sabe se tienen
conocimientos específicos sobre los
efectos de esta variante omicron sobre
la población más joven bueno todavía no
tenemos mucha información sobre estos
efectos se habla un poquito de que esta
variante puede ser un poco menos severa
en los adultos pero gran parte de esta
falta de digamos de severidad es porque
estos adultos han tenido muchas más
oportunidades para ser vacunados en el
caso de los de los niños menos del 25
por ciento de los niños de 5 a 12 años
en nueva york tienen las pautas de
vacunación completa en menos del 25 por
ciento entonces esa falta de severidad
digamos esa severidad un poco más baja
que vemos en los adultos no la vamos a
ver en los niños dado que no han tenido
todavía esa oportunidad para ser
vacunados
bueno y usted que tanto cree que va a
funcionar este levantamiento de las
restricciones con los países de áfrica
de viajes bueno sabemos que las
restricciones especialmente cuando ya
hay una transmisión comunitaria clara
tampoco tiene muchísimos sentidos a
restricciones de esas restricciones de
viaje lo que tenemos que hacer es
aumentar las restricciones toma
domésticamente asegurar el uso de
mascarilla en interiores limitar esas
esas aglomeraciones sobre todo en
espacios interiores y más ventilados y
por último es muy importante para los
niños garantizar que si los padres
tienen que quedar en casa porque los
niños están enfermos porque tienen
síntomas aún todavía no tengan un test
positivo pero tienen síntomas que esos
padres puedan quedarse en casa que
legrand esos recursos económicos esas
bajas laborales pagadas para poder
quedarse en casa y esto son estrategias
que yo creo que no sólo competen a la
ciudad de nueva york al estado de al
estado de nueva york sino a todo el todo
el país en quien está definido